imagine you were hungry and all you have
at home is a coconut some rice and an
egg if you have no clue and zero
creative thoughts you'd probably eat the
raw egg with unboiled hard rice while
staring at the coconut if however you
have memories of your dad cracking the
coconut and your mum boiling the rice
your brain can connect the dots and form
a new creative idea you boil the rice in
coconut water then fry it with the egg
and add coconut flakes voila
enjoy your meal creativity is our
ability to look at a problem and come up
with a good solution to solve it once we
understand this we realized that it has
nothing to do with the subject matter
job or what we study there are creative
inventors and creative artists but there
are also very creative cleaners and
highly creative teachers people we
worship for their creativity often just
connect different ideas in a beautiful
new way and make them commercially
successful while all of us are creative
we differ in the way that we are and to
what extent Michael Keaton came up with
the adaption innovation theory he
believes that when we solve problems
we're either more adaptive or more
innovative people who are more adaptive
creative try to do things better people
who are more innovative creative try to
do things differently to solve a
specific problem say that of smelly cat
litter both types would use a different
approach more adaptive types look for a
solution inside the box they might try
to create better cat litter by looking
at its chemical properties then increase
the size of the sand particles and
finally add some refreshing tropical
scent more innovative creatives think
outside the letterbox they come up with
cat diapers cat schools for good manners
or a robo cat
but there are also other differences
psychologist JP Guilford and some others
argue that there is divergent and
convergent thinking more divergent
thinkers a better coming up with lots of
ideas when they see a problem converging
thinkers see all the details and are
better at narrowing down the options a
diverse team is hands usually most
effective when trying to solve problems
a divergent thinker can list many ideas
after a convergent think Akande then
look at each option in detail and then
pick the best one the result is better
than if anyone would do it by themselves
a murder-mystery experiment involving
two groups of students shows how
creative diversity works Group a was
full of students from the same
background group B was also all similar
but joined by one single stranger the
students from Group A enjoyed the
process and felt like they worked
together very well the students in Group
B didn't like having a stranger in their
team but they solved the mystery twice
as fast and won the race the researchers
concluded that the stranger added a new
perspective making the group think
harder and making them more careful of
drawing fast conclusions or falling into
groupthink the result was a more
intelligent problem-solving process if
we want to become more creative we first
have to build a collection of knowledge
and memories ideally by seeking new
experiences only then can we increase
the dots in our brain that we can
connect Clayton Christensen from Harvard
Business School recommends that parents
should fix things at home all by
themselves
their children then learn that problems
can be solved by ourselves and in many
different ways
Jack Matson professor of creativity at
Penn State University recommends to
dress for failure this gives us a new
perspective and the ability to play new
roles March spin
of minute videos suggests practicing
saying yes because whenever we say yes
we open the door to new experiences can
you help me want to try my ice cream can
I talk to you yes yes yes we recommend
you do one thing you have never done
before every day for at least one week
maybe a month call your weird aunt talk
to a stranger eat using your left hand
or take a really really cold shower
every evening write down what you did
and what you've learned from it start
with the first new thing right now and
share your experience in the comments
below right after
you
you